Thank you.
GraphQL.
You might have heard of it by now, and, if
you have, you've heard about how to it's great
for performance, backwards compatibility,
and great for those hard to get out stains!
Probably!
There's seemingly nothing it can't do.
But have you wondered how?
How can GraphQL have these supposed superpowers?
I think the key to this lays in its basic
building blocks.
In this talk, we will start off by taking
a look at the schema definition language,
RSL, and the resolvers, and understand how
they work together to execute a query.
Then I will show ways to use these features
to graph all the things before finally entering
the "don't try this at home" portion of the
talk.
First, g, the ' day, how is it going?
We work on building tooling services and platforms
to enable at Red Bubble.
I'm the maintainer of Lis Sass and notes Sass.
So let's jump right into it.
The schema is the skeleton of GraphQL.
It's what gives it its shape.
Everything else builds on top of or happens
because of the schema.
It is defined using the schema definition
language.
We are we have an example schema.
We're using "type" to define conference.
Our conference type is a name field which
we set as a string.
String is one of the skeletypes, in graph,
and others like ints, floats, and booleans
and the other suspects.
We have a speakers' field which has an array
of the speaker type.
It's not a built-in type, so we define it
ourselves.
Our speaker has a name and a favourite emoji.
This gives me licence to use member throughout
the talk!
We have some fields with exclamation marks
and others don't.
It means a field is omitted but still valid.
IDs are convenient for querying and mutating
data.
Speaking of querying and mutating data, we
have the query types called root types.
There are others too but we're not going to
talk about them today.
On our query type, we have a conference field
that returns any conferences we know about.
We also have a speaker's field that has a
required emoji argument and returns some speakers.
We have a mutation type.
It has a speak field, that takes a speaker
ID and a Conference ID.
Something to note, it's common to refer to
fields on query mutation types.
You see return-type mutation looks like the
return type of a query field.
A field on a mutation could return things
like booleans but as richer types as part
of the expressiveness of GraphQL.
There is some detail as to how these are defined
that we won't go into today.
The important thing to take away from this
is the field in the query type to ask for
information whereas fields and mutation type
typically change things.
Lastly, the resulting data from mutation can
be expected to have the changes already applied.
The schemas are the skeletons of GraphQL and
at their beating heart.
They bring life to GraphQL.
With the amazing things that GraphQL can do,
you would think they would be pretty complicated,
but it's the simplicity of resolvers that
is the key to their flexibility.
It's just a function.
It takes a couple of arguments.
We're going to talk about these three today,
but there are others.
You can define a resolver or any or all fields
on your schema, including fields in the query
type, the speak field, and fields on any type
like the emoji field on the speaker type.
Inside a resolver, you can do anything it
could do in any other JavaScript function.
The only requirement is that it returns of
value in the shape that matches the type of
the field that it is responsible for.
Here we have a map of resolvers.
It has a query object representing the query
type.
And a query object, there is a speaker's resolver.
A speaker's query has an emoji argument.
We can access that argument by the name on
the arc's argument on its resolver.
We know from our schema that the query should
returning the or an array of speaker types.
Here it's returning an array of objects which
have an integer ID field and a name and an
emoji string field which means they match
the expected shape of the query and all is
well.
Remember, the conference field doesn't have
an exclamation mark so it's entirely optional
here.
Our speaker mutation - here we have a speaker
mutation loading data from the context by
the conference ID argument.
Conference is a bit special.
It makes it useful for storing things like
configuration or services like database connections.
After it is loaded, the speaker ID argument
is appended to the conference object, the
- finally does a query for the conferences
that the speaker is attending.
So that was a lot.
But it is just a groundwork for what is coming
up next.
We're going to take a look at practical use
of resolvers to feel how they work together
and give you the versatility of GraphQL.
The simplest resolver is one that returns
an object.
Earlier, we saw a resolver and all good because
it returned a resolver that matched the shape
of the speaker type before how does GraphQL
match the speaker shape?
Is there some kind of internal validation
engine or some form of intro expect on their
return type or AI?
GraphQL can do these magical things.
Why not build AI in there?
No doubt there is a way to return these types.
If you're like me, you're thinking about how
you would have done it yourself.
I've shown you how it happens.
Every field from GraphQL gets a default resolver.
The default resolver is straightforward.
For any field, it takes the object, the parent
object and tries to be the access a field
as a function call, or an object property
on the parent.
Importantly, this happens recursively, so,
if a field returns a type, the field's return
type is a custom type, then all the fields
on that type have their resolvers called.
This is what happens in our case.
The schema for our speaker's query returns
return type to a null or an array of speaker
type.
GraphQL takes the speaker value.
If it is null, it's returned.
If it is an array, the value is iterated over
and a resolver default is called for each
speaker field.
The parent armed for the resolver is the object
at the current loop of the array.
If a resolver for a field returns the wrong
time, GraphQL throws an error.
Also, if the return type of the initial speaker's
query isn't null or an array, we also get
an error.
The default resolver is a great example of
how we use building blocks to solve tricky
problems like validation.
So, a common use case for GraphQL is putting
it in front of existing APIs.
This really its bread and butter and what
gave it momentum to start off with.
Even here, there are interesting possibilities.
Here, I've updated our speaker query to make
an HTTP request instead of returning a hard-coded
API.
The schema could have different types.
In this case, you iterate over the JSON and
transform it to the phenotype you expect.
Once again, we've added the conference resolver
to the speaker type.
There are a couple of interesting things happening
here.
Firstly, using both jQuery and fetch.
Because, why wouldn't you?
You have the entire power of JavaScript and
MPM at our resolvers, so we might as well
use it all.
We are iterating over the array of speakers,
and for each of those speakers, the conference
resolver has called from an entirely different
API.
Here, GraphQL's essentially aggregating across
multiple APIs in order to resolve a single
query.
The remaining queries are resolved using a
default resolver.
You can have a resolver with any or all fields.
You can resolve all fields by its own API
and users wouldn't be any the wiser.
I'm not saying you should do this but you
could if you wanted to.
GraphQL got a lot of attention early on because
of how well it worked as a facade on top of
these fragmented APIs which often had incompatible
methods of authentication, different transport
types or content types.
We can expose a single interface over - you
have, APIs, without having to rewrite any
of them.
It wasn't long before people start rescinding
these ideas, sometimes cutting out the APIs
altogether and going straight to the database.
Some truly innovative people have gone as
far as defining the schemas themselves in
a different language.
Here, we are resolving a speaker query by
making a -gate query.
We are pulling the database operation - we
set this up earlier.
Because you have the full power of JavaScript
to get a disposal here, you can do all the
things you would do in an attractional RM,
like read or write instances, whatever the
requirements of that field might be.
If you can use a database, there's no reason
you can't use any other kind of of data store.
Here, we are mixing and matching between relation
al databases, elastic searches, at the field
resolver level.
Being able to make these choices at the field
resolver levels allows us to fit best-fit
solutions for the requirements of an individual
field and changes of requirements over time
as our systems change.
By no means saying this is unique to GraphQL,
simply aiming to illustrate the ease as which
these capabilities are achieved between - within
the play between schemas and resolvers within
GraphQL.
This is actually my favourite use case.
I said earlier that the platform team is a
bubble, we focus on enabling everyone, not
just engineers.
The way we do this is let people bring their
own tools and adapt our systems to work with
them.
Enter spreadsheets.
Who doesn't love a good spreadsheet in I know
I do, our copy writers do, our data scientists
do.
They're practically ubiquitous and this makes
them a powerful tool for enabling and encouraging
contributions.
Spreadsheets are fantastic for GraphQL because
they are already structured.
They come with their own schemas in the form
of columns and rows.
Here our speaker's query is loading it from
disk, filtering the speakers to knows matching
the emoji we passed them as a query alter.
Now, anyone in our organisation can drag and
drop a new spreadsheet on the GitHub UI.
This kicks off our pipelines, and if the test
passes, this is live for everyone to see,
no engineer was required for this process.
I mentioned at Red Bubble, we have a lot of
this GraphQL distributed and a lot of configuration
services to back this up.
These configurations services are different
to other services in that they fetch configuration
on deploy and fetch low locally.
They're not meant to be used in request.
They may get over-the-wire updates as their
lifetime goes on.
We like the approach for - but it covers the
complexities.
Is is is the configuration stored in memory
or on disk?
What happens when we receive an update?
How do we validate the new configuration?
We tried a few ways of managing and exposing
configuration in our services and as you might
expected, we eventually landed on GraphQL.
Loading configuration files in resolver is
pretty straightforward using the FS promises
API.
If we're unable to load the configuration
for any reason, the server fails to boot.
This works really well in many cloud environments
because currently running it deploys will
keep running until new versions can come up,
so we don't lose any downtime.
Next up internally, we created a configuration
object by querying for that GraphQL configuration.
If some important data is missing or if the
data is otherwise unsuitable, the query fails
and the service failed fails to boot again.
Here, GraphQL's acting as an internal API
abstracting over the node files APIs and abstracting
over the complexities of dealing with validity
and freshness.
So some of you may have the inned in a previous
slide, it was a chicken-and-egg scenario,
how to load configuration and put it in context
if we are loading configuration inside a resolver?
This is where we do something nifty.
We create multiple GraphQL servers with their
own schemas and resolvers.
One server handles incoming requests and reloads
configuration by querying the second GraphQL
server.
That's right.
You can even use GraphQL to abstract over
GraphQLs running on the same machine.
In fact, just about any API that is simply
reads and writes can be represented as GraphQL
queries and mutations.
This is a real - this got me thinking - a
light build up bulb moment for me.
What if our JavaScript APIs were GraphQL?
What if the browsers had a GraphQL interface?
This is my friends when things go off the
rails.
Welcome to the don't try this portion at home.
Don't try this at home portion of the talk.
I hope by now I've been able to convince you
that enough about any read or write interface
can be like plastered over with graphical
representation.
This got me thinking: the browser has read
and write APIs.
Surely these could have some graphical interfaces.
As it turns out, there's nothing about GraphQL
that inherently limits you in server environments.
As long as you have a schema and resolver
map, most implementations are happily run
in the browser.
Why?
I think there are a couple of good reasons
for this.
We live in a world of heavy browser feature
fragmentation, and even when those features
exist, like the rolled out in a progressive
manner, with API fragmentation in those features.
There's the complexities of dealing with progressive
enhance the and degradation because it's fun.
Admittedly, I did if for the fun, but there's
something valuable in the idea of the interface
across all our web languages.
Let's look at some examples.
We've looked at how we use resolvers to interact
with data stores, but the browser has a bunch
of its own data stores.
We have the web storage APIs in local storage
and session storage, web SQL databases, and
cookies.
With a bit of creativity, you can stuff any
kind of data inside a URL.
There's a handful of libraries that do this
for us acting as an interface across a buffer
of these storage engines with using a mix
of feature detection or polyfills.
And so abstracting over data source is something
that GraphQL is already good at.
It's a really great fit for the scenario.
We are, we've taken the spreadsheet consolidate
from earlier, but reading a file off disk
we're using it as an abstraction over various
browser storage APIs.
Libraries will progressively enhance or degrade,
depending on which APIs are available in the
current environment.
More importantly, the user APIs don't get
to juggle all the different APIs themselves
or learn a whole new third-party API.
They're just looking at the schema for the
types required and executing queries and mutations
as they already know how to on server.
Just like on the server, a browser has equally
capable of making network requests to APIs.
Just like on the server, we can call it working
APIs within the resolvers.
Just like - we can gratefully degrade depending
on what is available in the operating environment.
And that, my friends, is running GraphQL in
the browser.
I think that's pretty cool.
So I thought I would end it here.
Like, in many ways, browser JS isn't different
from the server side JS.
It's not surprising they're able to use GraphQL
as an abstraction layer over finicky APIs.
There's something unique to the browser.
Does GraphQL still hold up in this new world?
For example, our good old buddy, the DOM.
DOM libraries are nothing new.
Some started our JavaScript journeys with
DOJO.
Even new, like, in React - here is an example
of what a schema might look like for document
query selector.
All the dollar-sign functions in jQuery.
And this is what the resolvers might look
like.
We have a document query to get to our document
object and the document type has APIs we care
about and fields.
The resolvers for those fields just call methods
on the parent, the parent being document in
this case.
And I think things - things pretty much work
as expected.
By now, you should not be surprised by anything
on the slide.
It's like previous examples we've seen before.
The question you might have is why?
Why even do this?
And I get it: I was up front.
These aren't necessarily good ideas.
They're just ideas, but honestly, slides like
this I think is why.
Every time I forget to await my fetch only
to have JavaScript yell at me that I can't
use top-level awaits is why.
Every time I forget Node list aren't actually
arrays is why.
Every time I decide whether to have to decide
to use a callback or a promise interface is
why.
All the reasons you might use jQuery today
because it's easier is why.
Something about these slides really speaks
to me.
But I have to concede, building and maintaining
a schema like this for the entirety of the
DOM is kind of absurd.
I get shivers thinking about what it would
take to maintain.
So maybe some enterprising folks could generate
schemas and resolvers by scraping things like
MDN or W3C specs or get crazy with web IDL,
or maybe if we don't have the schema.
I know I spent you 20 minutes saying they're
amazing and the skeleton of GraphQL.
That's all true, but also I'm really lazy,
like super lazy.
Did you see that schema?
It's massive, and it's not getting any smaller
any time.
So if we don't have schemas, we don't need
resolvers, either.
I know, the beating heart of GraphQL, life
blood, blah, blah, blah ... if I squint my
eyes and tilt my head and use imagination,
this looks like the resolver we had in our
DOM APIs.
So what if we define our own default resolver?
A single resolver that was general enough
to handle any field for any DOM API, if it
follows a general pattern of fields being
properties or functions on their parents,
then we don't really need the schema.
Like the DOM is the schema, like MDM becomes
our schema.
I thought it was a nifty idea and gave it
a shot.
So I have some demos coming up.
I think this stuff is cool.
I've been told it's probably just me!
If you think this stuff is kind of cool, how
about giving it a clap so I know to continue.
[Applause].
All right.
So, in the interests of tile, I have demos
prepared earlier.
As I mentioned, we could abstract over things
like network requests.
So here we are making our request to some
random API that someone kindly allowed cause
on for me.
- calls on for me.
You can see here, we are essentially querying
for our window object, run the object calling
fetch.
In fetch, we're passing an array of arguments
that line up to the argument forward of the
fetch API.
We are saying fetch this URL and then causing
the JSON method on that response.
Under the covers, you may await this, but
you don't have to care about it.
It's done for you.
And here we can see the output, just for the
saying that I'm not lying.
And you can get the result here by calling
the path on which we made the query, so our
result is window reflect JSON.
You may think we've already showed how resolvers
can make requests.
This is different, it's not resolvers making
the network request, the query itself is the
network request.
We're resolving how to make requests.
It's a bit unique, I think.
So that is all well and good.
What about the DOM?
I promised the DOM.
So here, we're emulating what I talked about
earlier, we are taking - querying the document,
querying the query selector role and giving
it an parliament with the P tags.
On the resulting P tags, we're pulling properties
off.
I think of this like a map.
Like, what we've saved here, because you don't
have to know what this returns.
Is it an array, not an array?
How do we cast an array?
Is it going to yell at me?
All those areas you probably run into like
I have.
And we can see the output here.
We can see the properties coming out.
That's not going to impress you.
Let's try this one out!
So here, we're doing the same thing, except
we are using GraphQL aliases.
We are essentially saying passing a document
in, saying this is the root purely for the
sake of indentation and readability but also
for the sake that we can show we can operate
on the resolve to something else.
Passing in a document, doing three queries
of the DOM and assigning those results to
variables.
We are saying our good boys are querying for
all the Dojo emojis.
There are some dogs and not dogs here.
We're also querying for the non-Dojos, and
for the yummy Dojo.
These though you the results of the variables,
but really bringing this home, we can actually
pass this variable back into another query
as the context, and here, we are doing the
mutation, calling set attribute on our first
good est boy, and we are giving it a style
and increasing the font size.
If we scroll up - oh, I changed the name -
if we scroll up!
Giant hot dog!
[Applause].
As you may have guessed, this is the hungry
boy.
We can query the DOM, we can mutate the DOM.
What else can we do?
We can also do animations on the DOM using
web animation API.
Here, we are getting our hungry boy once again,
and we're using the web animation API by calling
animate on the resulting thing and giving
it the object of the web animation specs.
We are spinning it and scaling it up and down.
We can change these.
This is all live.
I'm not lying to you.
This is, like, so here we have had to do is
look at MDN, find the API, and it's the same
query interface.
We didn't care how it returned or how it worked.
If we want to reuse the animation?
How do we copy it around and use it?
We can use the GraphQL fragments.
We are querying two different nodes in our
yummy node.
We are giving a spin and a bounce animation.
These are defined down here asking from fragments
on the element type before we have one that
bounces and one that spins, and then named
as such.
If we uncomment this - woah, ... . Animations
as variables.
That's the best I got.
I'm sorry!
[Applause].
I know some of you are thinking: DOM, who
uses the DOM?
I'm more about the jQuery life.
For you, we have this.
We are passing our jQuery as the root context
and can call jQuery as northerly.
We're doing our request for the item and calling
animate function.
We're animating properties if the way that
you would in jQuery.
These can be used together.
There's no limit to the hilarity that can
ensue with enough animations.
Let's give this one more spin before I wrap
up.
And there we go.
GraphQL on the DOM in the browser.
[Applause].
In closing, I started by saying GraphQL superpower
be and shaped everything else like a - this
makes GraphQL infinitely versatile.
With a little creativity, we can GraphQL all
the things and move towards a universal query
language before the web.
Thank you.
[Applause].